joining me now is New York gubernatorial
candidate Lee zeldon Congressman CNBC
reported today that hokel's donors are
now sounding the alarm over your Surge
and begging her begging her in these
waning hours to Pivot to crime
but I guess that advice wasn't taken all
that seriously
yeah and the polls are going to close in
just under 24 hours now the time for a
pivot to being a crime fighter has
obviously come and gone not only has she
missed out on an opportunity to actually
connect with voters on an issue that is
most important so many of them she's
ridiculed them when she says that as she
doesn't understand why it's so important
to me that we need to lock up criminals
that's a message that is sent to All New
Yorkers what do you do when you dig a
hole she kept digging she went on MSNBC
and then she said this is a conspiracy
and then she says there were data
deniers so she kept digging she went on
CNN which she didn't realize was that
there was a side by side where next to
her while she's continuing this
narrative that you're talking about
they're showing all the different major
crime categories that are going up so
what does she do she went on MSNBC again
but the host actually cut her off and
said listen I'm not safe when I go to
the pharmacy everything's locked up and
I'm not right hitting the subway
New Yorkers of all walks of life forget
about just Republicans we're talking
about Independents and Democrats as well
have decided that you know she's not up
for the job she's not going to be
offering up bold Solutions she's not
going to hold Alvin Bragg accountable
for his refusal to enforce the law she
won't roll back pro-criminal laws like
cashless bail she's not going to
unapologetically back our men and women
in blue to give them the tools and
resources they need to do their job so
as a result come tomorrow I believe that
she's going to get fired by the voters
of New York who want to take their
Streets back well on NBC Nightly News
you'll be shocked to know that Lester
Holt delivered a completely impartial
report congressman
an issue Finding Traction for many
campaigns is voter worries about crime
but as we found the state of crime in
America is not always what it appears to
be tonight fear is on the ballot vote
like your life depends on it because it
does fueled some argue not by reality
but by videos of rampant lawlessness and
some unsettling headlines
well Congressman the media clearly see
how potent an issue crime is and they
are essentially as I said earlier
picking up the Baton from hokel and
Company to say look this you know I'm
not saying there's no crime but it's not
really as bad as people like you make it
out to be
I mean lesser Holt is playing this video
of of me on my front lawn with my wife
and kids we're right there just a few
weekends ago there was a gang drive-by
shooting my my two 16 year olds were at
home at the kitchen table doing homework
on a quiet Sunday afternoon there was a
bullet found about 30 feet away two
people shot laying on the ground about
10 feet away this is real life it was
the 1980s when elected officials were
trying to convince the public that it
was just a perception that there was
Rising crime and it wasn't until the
early 90s that New Yorkers of all walks
of life Republican Democrat independent
decided enough don't try to tell me that
this is just perception don't tell me
there's nothing to see here Look Away we
want people in government to actually do
what needs to get done to take back our
streets and Subways well fast forward to
2022 here we are again and New Yorkers
who are hitting their breaking point in
this state New York leading the entire
nation out migration one of the
key aspects of that is the affordability
of Life of New York attack on freedom
attacks on the quality of our education
but also safety and they've decided you
know what Kathy hokel's not up for the
job we're seeing strong support great
energy good momentum we just have to
make sure everyone shows up and votes
tomorrow vote like your life depends on
it because I believe that it does well
it's time for New York to make a
decision do you want to save yourselves
or not I mean if you don't want to save
yourself just keep doing what you're
doing but Congressman thank you and good
luck tomorrow can't wait to watch hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else